we must all hang together or most
assuredly we will all hang separately
that's where founding father Benjamin
Franklin had to say on signing the
Declaration of Independence and it
points up the riskiness fellow signers
were taking as an act of treason against
British rule they were putting their
very lives at risk and so too was a
woman you probably haven't heard of a
printer who created the first copies of
the famous document who liked the
founding fathers wasn't afraid to put
her name right on them Dana Jacobson
reports and this is one of the only
copies inside the Massachusetts archives
and Commonwealth Museum sits a national
treasure the Declaration then announced
the birth of our nation at a time I
think when so many issues and
controversies and turmoil is out there I
think this particular holiday the fourth
of July in this particular document
really is a thing that we can all unite
about and Secretary of the Commonwealth
William Galvin says if you look a little
closer at this copy
you might notice an unfamiliar name mary
catherine goddard she's at the bottom
she wrote printed in baltimore maryland
by mary catherine goddard her full name
really saying I support this cause and I
want my voice to be heard to princeton
historian martha king is writing a book
about female colonial printers including
goddard congress had fled philadelphia
this is in the middle of the war and had
settled temporarily in baltimore so she
happened to be the printer in baltimore
at that time in that moment congress
needs someone to print this declaration
with the names finally from July 4th 76
they want people to know who these
people are who put their names on the
line really an act of treason to put one
signature so she printed that in January
of 1777 although her name is not
well-known and no drawings of her exist
Goddard made an impression where over
nine years she really ran a weekly paper
in Baltimore a single woman doing this
too and she has the important
responsibility
so as postmaster for the town to make
sure the mail and the chain of
communication flows as a printer during
wartime news of battles news of what the
probable outcome of this were for
independence would be Goddard would be
post mistress of Baltimore for 14 years
technically the first female federal
employee until a new Postmaster General
replaced her with a man in the fall of
1789 over 230 Baltimore residents and
merchants wrote a petition in her behalf
she spoke up and she said this is unjust
treatment and tried to have it
remediated but was not successful King
used census in tax records to get a more
accurate picture of Goddard story like
many others of the time she was a slave
owner the 1790 census the first census I
was able to track her and find that she
owned four slaves and had one other free
person in her household at that time
Mary Katherine Goddard did have this
enslaved woman Belinda Starling that she
manumitted in her will she left all of
her personal property to her she
liberated a woman as her final deathbed
wish and I think there's more to that
that I want to study worry and find out
about open times I fear that women are
not included in the pages of history
and that has created an impression that
women were not involved for the fight
for independence and that is not true
Denise Van Buren is the president
general of the Daughters of the American
Revolution Mary Katharine Goddard should
inspire us today to raise our voices to
be part of the discussion and to help
chart the course for our nation it's so
important that we begin to recognize the
fact that not only women but people of
color foreign-born Patriots all
contributed to our victory during the
American Revolution
for printer and artist Mindy bellof Mary
Katherine Goddard has served as
inspiration we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal as a feminist artist
I felt the you know we're still sort of
grappling with with this language today
I spoke with some historians about what
all men meant at that time did it mean
all men or all white men who were
landowners or all mankind one British
historian felt that it was understood to
be all mankind I felt that it was time
to set the record straight to do so béla
recreated Goddard's printing of the
declaration with historically accurate
typeface and paper so this is the
historic recreation okay that's accurate
to what Mary Goddard printed and so in
the contemporary I changed the word men
in two places from we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal
it's mentioned twice here and so it's
rewritten as people belif sprinting czar
in the permanent collection of the
Library of Congress and other
institutions all men are created equal
did you put yourself in her shoes and
wonder what that might have been like
for a woman to be printing those words
at the time absolutely I wondered about
that quite a bit and how it was
understood when the enslaved and women
at that time were wanted a voice in this
new republic it was interesting for me
on many different levels especially when
we think about what's going on today and
how we use words and language and how
it's understood and and what an
important document this was at the
tumultuous times
and according to Martha King at this
tumultuous time as well I think with the
declaration of independence this call
for a united country based on the ideals
of equality rather than exclusion and I
think it Mary
that's reading the Declaration of
Independence in 2020 just as much as
people were reading it and signing it in
1776 does this ring true for us today or
is it still aspirational in some ways
sounds about right to me right Michelle
it's so interesting to see that
recreation and Mary Catherine got it a
name that I think a lot of people now
will not forget yeah I certainly won't
thank you so much Dana for bringing that
story to